ja
[Musik]
yahoo
ich bin sehr wichtig über ein geländer
vor wird die nach demokratie dass man
immer noch einer sagen was man gönnt und
nicht nur das meister die möglichkeit
[Musik]
ja
was man kann sagen ist das einfach die
initiative start bringen als möglichen
randgruppen politik sind sondern mit 51
prozent an bringt oder bekommen prozent
0 1% der kammer nicht bestimmen und es
geht ihr schluss gemacht
[Musik]
das ist dass kommunisten schweizer
fernsehen waren rechts
das lenke kommunistinnen argumentieren
dass die schweiz minarette verboten hat
das ist falsch
[Musik]
einige heikle initiativen sind schwierig
umzusetzen
darum lanciert die svp jetzt eine neue
initiative
[Musik]
ich begrüße sie recht herzlich zu
unserer medienorientierung betreffen der
dosierung unserer neuen volksinitiative
schweizer rechtsstaat fremde richter in
dem maß in dem das 5 recht über der
bundesverfassung steht in dem maß geht
die direkte demokratie kaputt das volk
dass ich mit der modernen rechtsstaat
was ist meins ist eine diktatur
[Musik]
guten morgen schweiz ein gespaltenes
land
der wille des volkes hat in den letzten
jahren zu problemen geführt
[Musik]
bis 11
der bundesrat der steckt im moment ganz
schön in der klemme er muss nämlich bis
februar 2017 die zuwanderungs initiative
der svp umsetzen und die hebelt die
personenfreizügigkeit mit der eu aus ich
bin ladin betriebsökonomie svp-mitglied
und ich bin für deshalb initiative will
das land kein problem hat und die
initiative versucht hat die probleme zu
lösen
es waren zeitungsschlagzeilen die sie
bewogen haben der svb beizutreten hier
der kriminelle ausländer dem eine teure
therapie bezahlt wird dort ein fremder
der die fürsorge austrickst
von ihrem wohnort an bord pendelt die 31
jährige täglich zur arbeit nach bern
der masseneinwanderung initiative habe
sie zugestimmt weil sie kein verbautes
land wolle
unterdessen in zürich
[Musik]
heißt es im mittelstand in der partei
haben aber alles auch wenig abgelehnt
grund ist die ziele zurückgeschraubt wo
er soll ihr täschchen noch nicht machen
auch die angehende
medienwissenschaftlerin fährt täglich
nach bern und sie ein praktikum bei
einer umweltorganisation macht für
überfüllte züge gebe es andere lösungen
als diese initiative die sie einen
holzhammer nennt die zugewanderten eine
bereicherung so denke sie seit ihren
aufenthalten in new york und wien im
rahmen des studentenaustausch programms
erasmus
großartige erfahrungshorizont gemacht
und also der erst die schale vor dem
adam west allis taxi das erasmus
programm wird gestrichen
wenn ich einfach nicht zustande
ich habe die erfahrung gemacht vor dem
und isoliere
weniger zuwanderung sagte das stimmvolk
der entscheid aber fiel äusserst knapp
die schweiz steht vor der grundsatzfrage
volkes wille oder ungehinderten
wirtschafts zugang zur eu
[Musik]
eigentlich handelt es ist ja nicht hier
und das ist eigentlich ein schöner
ausdruck von wut bürger die
unzufriedenheit mit der politischen
elite mit dem parlament und das
europäische geschickt sie bringt
regelmäßig vor lager wo große politik
und die migrationspolitik andere
position aufbringt das vp regiert
eigentlich stück volksrecht das heißt
sie versucht nicht mehrheit im parlament
zu finden konsensdemokratie ist das
natürlich enorme belastung die folge von
volkes wille jahrelange arbeit im
parlament kann zunichte gemacht werden
es entsteht unsicherheit
zwar hat der bundesrat unterdessen
gesagt er wolle eine schutzklausel
einführen aber genaueres weiß auch bei
zwei jahre nach der abstimmung niemand
unsicher ist doch simon knittel
situation sie macht ein praktikum und
fragt sich ob sie in zukunft noch im
ausland arbeiten kann
[Musik]
ihre deutsche arbeitskollegin an arbeit
hängt in der schwebe werden kontingente
eingeführt kann es sein dass sie trotz
guter qualifikationen die schweiz
verlassen muss anders martina berger
beruflich gesehen hätte die svp wählerin
keinen grund gehabt der
masseneinwanderung initiative
zuzustimmen bei der post arbeitet sie
nur mit schweizern zusammen und sie hat
eine kader- stelle
aber darum gehe es nicht
es gehe um die zuwanderung allgemein und
die sei viel zu groß in ihrer gemeinde
aber leben über 40 prozent ausländer
die fürsorge kosten seien hoch
verursacht werden sie aber primär durch
flüchtlinge und nicht von eu höhere auch
in simon knittel skat ihr zürich
altstetten leben mit 35 prozent
überdurchschnittlich viele ausländer die
eritreerin ghiberti hat sie an einer
integrations veranstaltung kennengelernt
wie stehen wir grundsätzlich zu jenen
die uns fremd sind positiv oder
skeptisch
es war diese haltung die laut
wahlanalyse den ausschlag gab
für knappe jahr zur masseneinwanderung
initiative die mit ihrem song steht das
eigentlich man da so machen und
versuchen einfach die regeln verstoßen
wie keine andere partei schafft dass die
svp bürger die sich von der
globalisierung bedroht fühlen zu
mobilisieren
in aarburg fürchten viele um nichts
weniger als ihre identität ist
ich mache mir nicht so soll die schweiz
also blut und kultur übernahme
sämtlicher ist schweizer willensnation
mit vier sprachen und viel kultur und
das land und das ist für mich als
genauso sie auf das bin ich stolz
den ersten august feiert sie nicht in
der schweiz
sie ist in bayern und sagt auch sie
fühle sich manchmal fremd in der heimat
aber nicht wegen den ausländern sondern
weil viel angst geschürt werde das
resultat der masseneinwanderung
initiative beschäftigt auch die
nördlichen nachbarn
[Musik]
deswegen finde ich auch sollte man nicht
alles dem volk komplett abstimmen lassen
es gibt experten die sich viel mehr
damit beschäftigen
das ist ein sehr hoher portdichte seine
zeit als von der haupt
das geschäft mit der xbox hinzu kommen
von dem spiel 6
[Musik]
es heißt immer mich als das was folgt
beschluss hat nicht umsetzen will das
übergeordnetem recht widerspricht und
mit übergeordnetem recht ist das
sogenannte völkerrecht gemeint
völkerrecht ist internationales recht es
betrifft zum beispiel die verträge mit
der eu oder die europäische
menschenrechtskonvention
das wird eine initiative das management
dass ausländische organisationen und
internationale gerichte das wegnehmen
und über unsere chronik über wird
direkter demokratie stand das ganze
kulminiert in diese initiative schweizer
recht statt fremde richter
sie werden nicht von mir aber dass ich
begeistert bin über diese initiative
aber lassen sie nicht einfach sagen nur
schon der titel ist hanebüchen ersten
mal sind ihr nicht fremde richter
wir sind eine europäische organisation
in der aus jedem land eine richterin
oder ein richter vertreten ist wenn
zählen kann
wenn eine frau 74 innen und recht wo der
europäische gerichtshof für
menschenrechte urteilt ich glaube sich
einen einfachen illusion zu meinen
souverän in die zukunft über probleme
heute wohnen internationale dimension
das land wollen wir aber bestimmt was
gilt geht sind die echse stand sowie ein
mensch wo er selber will über sich
bestimmen
zunächst stand aufgeht kann man stellt
das mit solar und kanzleramt soll das
mit vielen dank
über die folgen der initiative aber sagt
er nichts
es ist ähnlich wie vor der abstimmung
über die masseneinwanderung initiative
damals sagte die svp nichts über die
folgeprobleme mit der eu jetzt erklärt
folgt erst auf nachfrage die europäische
menschenrechtskonvention könnte
gekündigt werden
das ist richtig wann außerdem tatsache
eines shops initiative mit und
verwertete europäische mannschaft
kommission der mutter im extremfall
falls europa tausende bürger müssen
kündigung in kaufen werde ich sie
persönlich freue sich einzig aus
homosexuellen und wann sie jetzt in
russland würde glauben könnten sie
verrückt werden vom staat für die
homosexualität werden sie dann nicht
froh dass sie könnte dann international
nicht
es ist tatsächlich so dass so eine
schrift wie der europäische gerichtshof
ernannte 8 verkürzte staaten viel
wichtiger ist als für andere
wir sind solidarisch sie was ist es wert
dass für ihren finger zeigt ausgerechnet
als vorzeigemodell für demokratie
schweiz wird das ist sich einen gedanken
werbeformen wir freiwilligen könnten
die grösste partei spielt mit dem feuer
sagen kritiker der präsident der zürcher
svp hat einen speziellen bezug zu neuen
initiative aus dem nationalrat svp
schweiz relegation
wir sind in straßburg am sitz des
europarats der europarat wacht über die
einhaltung der menschenrechte
ausgerechnet der präsident des radikalen
zürcher flügels vertritt seine partei er
führt eine svp besuchergruppe hier
arbeitet die schweizer richterin helen
keller
mit der eu hat der europarat aber nichts
zu tun
er ist eine eigenständige institution
mit 47 mitgliedstaaten von island bis
aserbaidschan
die schweiz ist seit 1963 dabei
im europarat debattieren parlamentarier
über demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit
seine wichtigste errungenschaft die
europäische menschenrechtskonvention
jener vertrag also der gekündigt werden
könnte wenn die neue svp initiative
angenommen wird
die schweiz ist mit 12 parlamentariern
vertreten aktuelle präsidentin doris
fiala von der fdp wie alle mitglieder
des europarates verabschieden die
schweizer nur empfehlungen
am nächsten morgen in diesem vier sterne
hotel steige er immer ab sagt
nationalrat her den aufnahmen zu diesem
film hat er nur zögerlich zugestimmt
es gehört zur strategie der svp führung
journalisten des gebührenfinanzierten
schweizer fernsehens zu kritisieren
die svp will teile des öffentlich
rechtlichen senders privatisieren
[Musik]
alfred heer im persönlichen umgang
sympathisch kaum aber läuft die kamera
werte zum provokateur
warum überhaupt ist der hardliner im
europarat
es ist toll aus
dieses amt mit
alle haben aber das ist natürlich so
dass im prinzip französische nagel stück
grüner will das natürlich die weder
hauptsprache sind wir da wo du kriegst
werden aber das geht natürlich auf die
sprachen der vertreten dass in der
freisinger um zone könnte dass sich
vorgänger felix jährige sagte im
europarat bekäme man einen anderen blick
aufs weltgeschehen das habe ihn
überzeugt stand er in der schweiz macht
einfach machen lassen wir zählt einfach
das schweiz will macht wie alle anderen
und das mir eigentlich keine schlacht
gewinnt man eigentlich von den ein
anderer wanderer immer relativ groß die
hand dass man müsste ihnen achtung auto
er sagt er sei nur im europarat um die
position der svp einzubringen
zum beispiel in der migrationskommission
es ist frühling und alfred heer ärgert
sich über italien wegen der
flüchtlingskrise erfüllt der
nachbarstadt das dublin abkommen nicht
mehr viele flüchtlingen die aus italien
in die schweiz reisen werden nicht
zurückgenommen von 12.000 fällen aus
italien konnten das letzte jahr nur 3000
zurückgeschickt werden
ich bin erstaunt dass italien es nicht
schafft flüchtlingsfamilien
unterzubringen und die bedingungen der
europäischen menschenrechtskonvention
einzuhalten
es ist eine schande annette groth von
der deutschen partei die linke ärgert
sich über das votum der schweizer
kollegen
er hat jetzt eben die menschenrechte auf
gesprochen wie italien nicht einhält und
pocht auf die einhaltung der
menschenrechte in der schweizer seine
partei ist aber die initiative
landesrecht vor völkerrecht initiiert
das heißt dass man auch in kauf nimmt
die menschenrechtskonvention zu kündigen
das kann man nur sagen dafür nicht
schockierend zu klären das sagen und
jetzt und wir müssen es viel stärker
wieder propagieren und darauf achten
einhaltung der menschenrechte bei uns
wie woanders auch er sie lebt in einer
parlamentarischen demokratie und kann
die schweiz nicht beurteilen die
schweizer nicht aber sie aber nie
abgestiegen in der schweiz bestimmt
verstehen würde ich bin sehr froh dich
das sagen zu hören denn in der schweiz
über schengen dublin hat ja die
bevölkerung gefunden und es wurde uns
nicht einfach übergestülpt ist 55 nicht
umgesetzt
so sehr es die richter dieser und wieso
wird aber nicht umgesetzt werden es ist
immer zu haben dass er schwarz und ich
brauche mir gut das alles ist das
völkerrecht feld wir sind einfach
benachteiligt überall und immer das hat
auch dieser diskussion
der zwist mit alfred heer scheint fdp
frau doris fiala zu verärgern
in vielen fragen sind sich die
bürgerlichen parteien fdp und svp einig
aber in der eu politik haben sie sich
entzweit
trotzdem sagt doris fiala sie wollen
nicht her es gegenspielerin sein
das angebot eine größere rolle in diesem
film zu spielen lehnt sie ab doris fiala
sagt der populismus der svp mache die
anderen parteien ohnmächtig kolportiert
halbwahrheiten unterrichtsniveau wo sie
könnte so eine komplexe situation
beschrieben erklären und dem gemacht hat
und das macht sie unter aber plötzlich
hilflos wählt ihr freifach ich das
rezept eigentlich europa wie vor viele
populistische partei und die andere so
viel ich weniger korrupt rief er die
henkel tine 3 und klara sich hier und da
unbefriedigend unter dem ihr schaffen
vergleichen wir also die vereinfachungen
mit den fakten im parlamentssaal des
europarats sitzen über 300 politiker aus
47 ländern
alfred heer kritisiert die sogenannten
fremden richter am
menschenrechtsgerichtshof
tatsächlich aber sind es die politiker
des europarats die diese richter wählen
mit geheimer stimmabgabe
ein wahres parlamentsmitglied die
richterin mit französischen demokrat das
aufstand ich will mir nie vorgestellt
das war über drei richterinnen und
richter bestimmt dass der gerichtshof
für menschenrechte aber ist ein
internationales gericht
hier können bürger gegen irland klagen
wenn sie alle nationalen instanzen
ausgeschöpft haben
ich heiße nob da ich bin seit über 20
jahren journalist ich habe vor allem
schweizer gerichten verloren und bin
jetzt in straßburg ich bin sehr froh
dass es den menschenrechtsgerichtshof
der jurassier hatte einen artikel über
einen raser geschrieben er zitierte aus
polizeiakten in der schweiz wurde er
verurteilt wegen veröffentlichung
geheimer dokumente hier in straßburg
aber kehrten die richter das urteil
die schweiz hat die
meinungsäusserungsfreiheit verletzt
die schweizer behörden haben betas fall
innerhalb des gerichtshofs weitergezogen
die svp kritisiert dass hier auch
richter aus ländern arbeiten die die
menschenrechtskonvention nicht einhalten
wie russland für die befürworter ist der
gerichtshof ein wichtiges
sicherheitsnetz jeder in der schweiz
kann hier die menschenrechtskonvention
anrufen zum beispiel wegen des
minarettverbots oder künftig wegen der
automatischen ausschaffung im
konfliktfall will die svp darum die
menschenrechtskonvention aufkündigen und
aus dem gerichtshof austreten
damit niemand mehr überprüfen kann ob
heikle initiativen die menschenrechte
verletzen aber ist nicht genau umgekehrt
die letzte für jetzt klar sind 5000
urteil gefällt wurde und die
allerwenigsten betrachtet kriminelle
ausländer beschaffte sich doch genau
umgekehrt verhält dann sagen sie mir am
anfang war ein schweizer oben etwas
wesentliches skoda hat das gibt es gar
nicht das zeigt die phase wo man darauf
bauten weil die pauke segeln
ein schutz für die bürger ich kann da
erwischte vor mir vor deiner fall wo
beschwerte führung beschwerdeführerin
recht überholen schöneberg durch
neutronen prominente schweizer hinter
die meisten dieser fälle machten keine
schlagzeilen so wie jener von arno beta
helen keller sagt die schweiz wird in
nur 2 prozent aller fälle gerückt die
medien aber fokussieren auf aufsehen
erregen der einzelfälle
schweiz darf drogendealer nicht
ausschaffen straßburg rüffelt die
schweiz familie geht vor sicherheit
[Musik]
helen keller sagt es gelte in jedem fall
abzuwägen wie gefährlich ist der täter
und wie gut ist er in der schweiz
integriert der user hat nichts mit
kriminellen drogendealer egal wann sie
sich wieder gut benehmen auf deliktische
montags ist gefahr sich einfach nicht
ganz so simpel wann die personen noch
hinter uns sind diese fälle sind
umstritten aber sie kommen sehr selten
vor seit dem jahr 2000 rückte straßburg
die schweiz nur viermal wegen der
ausschaffung von kriminellen ausländern
das schweizer volk aber hat die
ausschaffungspraxis verschärft
[Musik]
der nationalrat hat die svp
ausschaffungsinitiative mit härte
klausel umgesetzt
aber die svp möchte eine härtere
umsetzung und deswegen mit ihrer
durchsetzung sind aktive hier ist die
welt noch in ordnung
kriminelle ausländer aber werden auch
fünf jahre nach der abstimmung noch
nicht automatisch ausgeschafft
martina berger sagt ein ausländer der in
einen laden einbrecher und zigaretten
und bargeld stehle müsse automatisch
ausgeschafft werden auch wenn er hier
geboren sein
aber die schweiz ist bundes stehe ich
ja natürlich richtig wichtig mindestens
die stattliche baum muss verhältnismäßig
sein
da ist jetzt genau auf da muss man doch
der einzelboxen einflussgröße geschätzte
ihrem war woods war natürlich muss es
mäßig sie aber war man sich einig war
meine vergangenheit nur wie auch nicht
in tschita habe denn ich es eigentlich
immer für das opfer ist ein cleveres so
gut wie verschwunden sagt gab es großes
problem dass die es war überhaupt nicht
traut und wieso seid hey wenn man den
automatismus machen
mit diesen maschinen zu blöd zum dass
sich gerade die kleine zuvor am besten
spricht die keine frau die keine
simon knittel und ihre kollegen finden
es unverhältnismäßig dass ein
einbruchdiebstahl oder der missbrauch
von fürsorge geld reicht um einen täter
aus zu schaffen
egal wie lange er in der schweiz lebt
oder wie hoch seine strafe ist
[Applaus]
funktioniert die heutige
ausschaffungspraxis wirklich so schlecht
wie svp frau martina berger sagt mit dem
vorschlag einen verurteilten ausländer
zu besuchen ist sie sofort einverstanden
vorläufig gilt noch das alte recht ab
einer haftstrafe von einem jahr bedingt
oder unbedingt wird die ausschaffung
eines verurteilten ausländers geprüft
zb name wollten ich bin unter anderem
ein rating und der kommunalpolitik
verdient mit dieser idee svp und sie wie
lange sind jetzt da knopfaugen und krank
ist und wie auch sie liga
[Musik]
ok also in klein liefern
ok rz stammt aus dem kosovo als
einjähriger kam er in die schweiz mit 14
wurde er kriminell ladendiebstähle
raubüberfälle schließlich eine schwere
körperverletzung wenn er seine strafe
abgesessen hat wird er ausgeschafft
verstaucht okay für das delikt marken
das nie mehr wirklich ewig rap ist hart
aber formiert das mit der usa abgespielt
produkt über strafen für mich rechtlich
allerdings will ich etwas mache wenn ich
sport es braucht nur richtig kann wie
ich doch alles schon verständige aber
dafür kann ist ja und wie brauche ich
überhaupt nicht sagen
und jetzt soll ich dann denken die
fußballerin wo der aufbau symbol
proteste und das ist man den noten die
frage wieso und es sieht einfach
auseinander setzen mit mir zum tage der
mensch ist sozusagen wieder ich bin ja
ich glaube für mich auf den schweizer
offen ließ sie ob das sind jetzt fast
arrogant man diese besagt was sie da für
antwort die gewinne dank johannes
gestrafft ob und wann sie von fremden
land als erfundene schweizer bis über
kommen dann muss nur die recht und
gesetz und sie kann muss man
respektieren sagen dass fremdes land
möglich dass überhaupt kanzler und das
die bürger liegt als kind oder ein
schweizer kriminell
das ist so ja das ist wirklich so also
da nicht sitzen gemäss der ausschaffungs
initiative hätte herr z die schweiz
schon mit 14 verlassen müssen als er zum
ersten mal in einen laden einbrach im
kanton zürich konnten in den letzten
jahren nur rund zehn prozent der
verurteilten ausländer ihre ausschaffung
auf dem rechtsweg verhindern
im kanton st gallen sogar nur rund
viereinhalb prozent aber martina bürger
und die mehrheit des stimmvolks wollen
nicht dass richter entscheiden
das volk soll bestehende schweiz bis
lauft und das exekutiv legislativ
operativ trauter und ich finde es nicht
schlecht wenn es folgt fragt wie möchte
dass man das ist sache des volkes
das ist absolut wichtigste dass das volk
stelle einfach fest
der justiz spielraum weg sky unter
dahinter ist relativ ja sag jetzt mal
falsche vorstellung dass es fünf was
immer das auch ist einzufangen
entscheiden
es folgt das gericht
das hat das verbindet begriffe
[Musik]
nach dem minarett verbot kommt jetzt das
verhüllungsverbot auf die politische
agenda heute lanciert ein komitee um svp
nationalrat walter wobmann eine
volksinitiative das tragen von
gesichtsschleiern in der öffentlichkeit
untersagen will ich finde es muss
möglich dass frauen von ihrem glauben
aber für mich ist ob durch kreis symbol
von einer extrem islam in frankreich hat
das land das burka verbot und aus sich
jetzt gestützt wurde vom europäischen
mannschaften bietet das bis ich es zeigt
vor allem der achter dass der
europäische gerichtshof für mannschaft
durchaus ökologisch also der schnitt
politisch motiviert da setzt generell
für gesellschaft die aber dafür der
einzelnen berücksichtigt
das sind frankreich dass man so der
kultur gezeigt und frankreich hätte das
problem mit islamisten in aarburg sagt
svp politikerin martina bürger ihre
gemeinde seit zwei geteilt die ausländer
würden vor allem im nördlichen teil
wohnen
die moschee
es gibt sogar neu treten sofern die
software jetzt in glaube aber dass jetzt
da ihre debatte sprachen morde früher
was einem sonnenaufgang das direkte
demokratie wie kommt der tyrannei der
mehrheit kann also das heißt dass er
absolute mehrheit übrigens im internet
bestimmt was mich dass religiöse
minderheiten im verlauf folgt vom
bundesstaat regelmäßig sie diskriminiert
wurde allerdings vor allem im
kultusbereich weniger version technische
freiheiten es zum gang ist dass sie ihre
kulturelle eigenheiten und weil dahinter
natürlich identitätskonflikt steckt
angst es ist ja gewisse angst vor dem
fremden vom neuen vormann
[Musik]
einspruch
die minarette die schweiz
[Applaus]
alfred heer wieder einmal dort wo man
ihn nicht erwarten würde der europarats
delegierte beobachtet im sommer die
türkischen bahnen ist seine abneigung
gegen minarette wirklich so groß wie
ernst sind seine markigen bemerkungen
vor der kamera gemeint immerhin hat er
drei jahre lang in der stadt new york
gelebt das problem mit meiner schüler
auf der walz bericht von haustieren und
sie hat nicht profitiert er weiß dass
robert typische land gleich kinder waren
darunter
es geht der ba trophy kreis sind und
trotzdem völlig würden also sie sind und
das sagen haben und sagen amri der svp
könne man nicht irgendwie über althofen
sie aber wir sehen ja alles ganz einfach
froh über die vorteile von der schweiz
heute zu bewahren
natürlich ist das lügen propaganda eine
super typ sie ist klar sie spricht nur
über die schweiz also ich bin zwar ein
stück habe ich lebe den land leben zwar
nicht aber ich komme auf das ohne sehe
wie hier die leute gut geht sie können
hier vor der moschee mit dem kreuz
herumlaufen und die sag ihnen keiner was
aber wenn sie in berlin mit einer kopf
rumlaufen in marzahn-hellersdorf und
damit ihnen dort bekommen sie von mir
sprechen sich in diesen verfahren
am ende verlor nicht mehr richtig
sprechen sie mit ihm sagen die
freundinnen bringen wo wir hier wir
haben zum beispiel hier in der fremde
preis der rechtskonservative den
nationalstaat umso mehr
die schweiz solle nur für sich selber
schauen
aber was tut er dann in der türkei als
wahlbeobachter hilft er nämlich das land
zu demokratisieren
die mitglieder des europarats sollen
sicherstellen dass die wahlen korrekt
ablaufen
total erich böhme werden
der svp mann aus der vorzeige demokratie
beobachtet wie die unterdrückte
kurdische minderheit versucht die erste
prokurdische partei ins parlament zu
wählen
sagen sie mir nicht welche partei sie
wählen wollen schauen sie sich die
symbole an und stempeln sie wird die
neue svp initiative angenommen wird die
schweiz wohl aus dem europarat austreten
müssen und keine walbeobachtungen mehr
machen warum also ist der svp-stratege
überhaupt in die türkei geflogen
seine partei hat den nutzen von
parlamentarier reisen und die kosten für
den steuerzahler in mehreren vorstößen
hinterfragt die frage bleibt vertritt
der stratege die reine lehre der svp
das fremd direktere preise selbst
bestimmen das ist die selbstbestimmung
initiative geht um die souveränität die
vermarktungsstrategie der initiative die
das völkerrecht einschränken will ist
clever und es unterschreiben viele in
den drei stunden während derer wir
filmen nur worum es geht weiß niemand
genau
und das sagt mir ganz klar
wir erinnern uns nur zwei prozent aller
schweizer gerichts urteile werden von
straßburg gerügt
die rechtlich wohl heikelste aller
svp-initiative nach acht monaten nur
sind die nötigen 100.000 unterschriften
beisammen zuschauer tendenz jsvp hat das
möglichst volk über möglichst viele
sollen das andere gewalt ist im
stadtparlament regierung total
geschwächt werde und dass am schluss
tatsächlich so bist wie eine tyrannei
der volksmehrheit konnte beste wenn man
demokratie nur noch aus unmittelbaren
und direkten volkswille wieder ruhiger
zurück im europarat die direkte
demokratie der schweiz sei das beste
politische system der welt sagt alfred
heer
je mehr macht das volk aber bekommt
desto größer wird auch der druck auf die
richter sind wo mir abgestimmt wird
weder busters das militär
was wäre dann die eigene rechte
abschaffen konsequenz ist dass ich etwas
gegen oder heißt das beißt besteuert
wird und dass wir mal richtig versteht
erleichtern schreibt mir vorstellen dass
das vp generelles problem hat mit walter
theilig und waren heute einfach nur mit
blick auf internationaler ebene also
dass bettencourt hat sondern auch mit
der unabhängigkeit vor dem stets im
marketing direktor mak wandern sondern
auch bundesverfassung und warum es will
mancher nachvollziehen
am ende des arbeitstages begrüßt der
schweizer botschafter einen teil der
schweizer delegation der unterdessen
abgewählte grüne ständerat luc recordon
der zurückgetretene sp-nationalrat
andreas gross und elisabeth schneider
schneiter von der cvp
menschenrecht mit rechtsstaatlichkeit
und demokratie frage innerhalb für
europa und für mich dass seine
mannschaft eine errungenschaft war mir
schon mit 740 mitgliedstaaten und
verdanke ich es umso erstaunlicher dass
man eigentlich die errungenschaft jetzt
aufs spiel setzten sondern sagen dann
kann doch wenn jemand alle wissen dass
die initiative die show die rechte und
die die wenigsten hätten die
schiedsrichter die mit gurt geräusch
herausforderung ist keine eigentliche
demokratie das ist dass das endgültige
team wie weit will die grösste partei
gehen und sind alle ihre strategen
wirkliche überzeugungstäter
und ich verstand da vergangen wie so oft
er ist fotograf im sog eines schnitts
anfang der bibel vorgelesen und einer
liste parteipräsident was ich muss
abgrund sofort einer welt wo mir die
hand wie sie irgendwo das als großer
konflikt würdige und nehmen im agro
heran wie mit dem parteiprogramm allem
parteipräsident und gerade wenn es vor
parteiisch dvd svp eine gewisse schärfe
hat danach eine wird man in vielen
tiroler politiker und ihre rollen mehr
als alle anderen parteien wissen die svp
strategen die direkte demokratie für
ihre zwecke einzusetzen
es war einmal ein kleines land mit einer
großen tradition die direkte demokratie
ein perfektes system fasst die letzten
jahre haben gezeigt dass das volk seine
macht auf die spitze treiben kann
es hat auch die menschenrechte von
minderheiten gericht die initiative dann
umgesetzt werden wenn funktion
grundsätzlich schon das macht ja die
direkte demokratie muss dann ja dann
finde ich das funktioniert äußerst
system schon heute kann man in der
schweiz notfalls noch den menschenrechts
gerichtshof anrufen
mit ihrer neuen initiative nimmt die svp
in kauf dass dieser schutz aufgekündigt
wird abgeschafft wird
ich setze auch lars interessantes
experiment darin dass verstöße linken
lustig findet auch nicht einfach blieb
und lüge dass das in meiner musik sie
das als vor oder nachteil diskutieren
rat nachteil nicht nur vorteile
mächtiger das volk wird desto enger
werde wahrscheinlich minderheit denn das
problem haben das ist ja eins immerhin
radio aus dem raum ist farblich sehr
schön und die anderen und das land
meiner wahl ich weiß nicht was ich weiß
ist er kritisch
das war demokratisieren
erbschaft des stadtturms typ wie das
demokratie ist gut richtig und glycin
nicht unvernünftig weil es findet eine
auseinandersetzung stopfen rädern
abstimmen und zwar zu extremismus s5 ist
einfach immer noch einmal weise
folterspuren und politiker müssen danach
ins spiel
[Musik]
im nationalrat gibt es einen klaren
rechtsrutsch grosse siegerin ist die svp
ihr anteil ist so hoch wie noch nie
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was der ezb an stoff gehörten
sprengstoffgürtel
[Musik]